why is it that they can't see and change
like why they see perfectly why should
they change this is this is the
philosophical part of the therapeutic
process I I love this part but let's
think about this it's working they're
right they're right it's working just
fine for them and it may as well be to
them like ancient Greek they don't know
what we mean intimacy and vulnerability
what are these vague Notions
I've never felt feelings I don't I felt
rage I felt lost I felt Envy
no but intimacy can I eat it can I have
sex with it I'm not can I wear it as a
Gucci handbag no I'm not intimacy you
can keep it they're fine they have no
interest in changing therapy is nothing
but an opportunity for them to flex
their muscles and stretch their claws
and practice what they do they charm the
pants off therapists they'll say this is
the best therapy you're so good
because there's there's never ending
supply of people yeah there's a
never-ending supply of people so since
their abuse goes on the outside to
protect them and essentially on the
other side of the coin the the
codependent is hurting themselves over
and over again they can't escape
themselves so you actually end up
reaching a Breaking Point unlike a
narcissist who just moves on to the next
people which is why you see them have
new friends all the time and they have
to keep turning this sort of system over
and over and over because they eat them
up right like they can eat that Gucci
handbag people like they can eat them up
over and over and over again is that why
that's it if it works if it's the
classic grandiose narcissist now if it
fails and they're the vulnerable
narcissist so the classic grandiose
narcissist thinks they're amazing and
largely they get the world to agree
the vulnerable nurses thinks they're
amazing when largely they can't get the
world to agree but yeah if they can if
they can if they can do it they don't
care they won't miss you they won't miss
you because they don't know you they
don't know who the hell you are there's
there's only an internalized
representation of you drawn in 2D and
crayon by a four-year-old child of you
you will have the experience when you're
with them this person knows me better
than my mother than my father than God
himself they haven't got a clue who you
are not a clue all they're doing is
how did they love bomb the out of
you to tell you all the things that
needed to be heard to buy in because
we're open books and we don't know that
we think we're so complicated and so
complex and it's written all over our
silly little faces and they ask
questions too
like what is it that I should never do
to make sure that this lasts all you do
is tell them the keys to the kingdom of
pain yes yes anything you say Canon will
be used against you is ammunition and
torture later on
it's so true okay let's talk a little
bit of like that cycle like I don't know
if people are hanging in there I'm sure
that they they probably know this but
like explain this cycle of a narcissist
to someone who might not understand yeah
they find you and they idealize you
then you're drawn into a sort of a
covert contract with them through some
sort of bait now they need the bait will
either be money or fame or love or
um access to something it's pretty
demonic you know there's a lot of like
deals with the devil sort of thing like
contracts and all that that goes on once
they've got you you enter into a shared
fantasy space with them this was a this
the shared fancy was identified by a
psychotherapist called Sande in 1989 all
of us have a shared fantasy when we're
in relationships It's Perfectly Normal
but the narcissistic shared fantasy is a
very dark one so the shared fantasy that
you're then trapped in sort of functions
like the Matrix you then submerge into a
simulated reality so life with a
narcissist has a very unique flavor
because it's not real it's a kind of
flight of fancy a foliage that the two
of you have created you sort of idealize
each other but particularly day idealize
you in the lock warming phase and then
you're trapped in a virtual reality
simulator of their design so you will
actually genuinely feel better about
yourself you think but what you're
consuming is narcissistic Supply not
genuine self-love so then sadly dear
viewers we become addicted to
narcissistic Supply and in this way we
become micro narcissists it's a it's an
infection you have to become emotionally
literate you must connect with your
emotions again
so one of the classic things I get in
coaching with people is um they'll sort
of cry and they'll go I already did the
work I went to therapy for 10 years and
I'll always say but if you didn't learn
to access and make friends with your
emotions again all of that therapy was
for nothing you must become emotionally
literate you can't live life as an
emotional letter it's not going to work
your emotions are part of you as much as
your hands and your feet are you cannot
deny the existence of your hands and
live healthily nor can you deny the
existence of your emotions so where your
real self is is where your feelings are
and not saying become blindly submissive
to emotion never we should always use
reason first but how you actually
authentically feel about pineapple on
pizza
is who you are
um I'm really glad you said that because
the yeah because you know your your
emotions are not something that you're
oh like especially if you're more
codependent you have created a
relationship with and they are
essentially the root of boundaries then
is to know yourself to know how you feel
so you don't well you're you're not even
actively abandoning them before that
you're just that's just your pattern so
like being able to tap into that is um
definitely a navigation tool out
how was it when you interviewed Sam um
how do you pronounce his last name
vacnan sambachmann yes I like saw that a
long while back and I was like man what
would that be like knowingly sitting
with such an
such a narcissist and he's like out
there he's one of those guys that's like
a self-aware narcissist but still a
narcissist does that feel weird do you
feel like you're always like getting set
up or something
um Simon's a person he's PR is pretty
polite to be honest with you uh most of
the time so it's it's it's okay
um for me as a business person and as a
professional to do that but I don't
recommend that anybody else engage in
contact with him it's it's very
dangerous he's a he is openly as you
just said admittedly a very very sick
man so people people really should bear
that in mind at all times and and really
keep it keep a distance from him you
really have to know what you're doing to
be in contact with it with a man like
that speaking of contact then there's
the guy uh tutor he wrote the book no
contact HG Tudor yes yeah yeah and he is
totally like I mean he I think he even
says that his sort of activism around
narcissism is being a narcissist yes
yeah yeah yeah no it's uh it's it's it's
interesting like
um the people who are online who who are
coming at it from that point of view but
what my uh like followers and viewers
and clients will say they get a lot
from that they like to hear from people
who've been diagnosed with narcissistic
personality disorder because it gives
them direct insight into into the way
those people think would you like
philosophizing about let me ask that
first well I'll tell you what I like
philosophizing about and I'll I'll
answer it in a way that'd be useful to
your viewers if they've been a
narcissistically abusive relationship
okay moral philosophy is very important
if you're in an abusive relationship and
you're looking to get out and then
you're looking to recover you have to
have a very
substantial conversation with yourself
with your pastor with a therapist or
somebody about your moral philosophy and
you really need to figure out we all do
whether you're a codependent or not
because our cultures become incredibly
morally relativeistic which is very
dangerous for everyone you really have
to figure out for you as an individual
what is right and what is wrong and I
don't think there are answers I don't
like rigid dogmatic answers I like
asking the question I like to be skilled
at asking and wrestling with that
question like when is it context
specific if it's wrong in this culture
is it right in another so on and so
forth but I like to have that that's
what where I start all the what is the
mean of Life why are we here is this a
simulation a narcissist it's all archons
what's going on
oh my god well the first thing I was
going to ask was about archetypes
because I thought that'd be such an
interesting sort of slight slanted
direction to go is like the archetype of
the but I changed my question I want to
know what you how you define morality
because you said earlier when we were
talking we should talk about that so
let's philosophize about morality but
let's start off with what is that what
is it to you what is your definition of
morality
um largely speaking I I think it's that
simple dichotomy of of good versus evil
I think a human being needs to have a
sense of this person or this situation
might be attractive
but it's evil so I'm not going to do it
and I was raised uh Christian so for me
it's that's where there is a religious
element there's a spiritual album that
comes into it and I have to think of the
seven deadly sins you know the sin the
sloth there's rage there's lust
what's the Temptation here and is this
wrong now if it seems to be like it's
going to be really fun or really
pleasurable or it's going to give me
some payoff in the material Realm of the
of the of the flesh like it's going to
make me famous it's going to make me
Rich there's going to be some pleasure
there there's going to be some payoff
there
um but I know that it's morally wrong am
I going to do it or not now if I have a
strong moral code in my body somatically
I won't be able to do it it's not a
question of me going I really want to
but I'm not going to my body will reject
it if I have a strong moral code if I
have a weak moral code it's going to
become a wrestling match between the
Angel and the devil if you like this
clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen